[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivey alongside aaron
dolan aaron
and be tested positive for covet
how are you feeling about your sixers
right now
all i'm thinking is yikes they've
already been riddled by the kova 19. we
had a few players out last week now
dwell embiid has it confirmed yesterday
so he's going to miss 10 games so come
later in the show we'll talk more about
the game tonight but just in general
this is definitely going to be something
that impacts the odds in terms of joel
embiid's mvp case definitely will take
definitely will impact his mvp odds as
always we're giving away locks
giving away hoodies and giving away
jersey so get in the comments please get
in the comments send gifts send emojis
and type out this type out winners only
please hit the send button fill those
comments up i'm giving away jerseys
actually
i'm gonna give away a jersey right
now aaron i am in the handy dandy ipad
right now uh
looking for a take looking for a take
and i see i see t thomas what are you
some good ones guys yeah definitely need
some good ones i see t thomas 444 says
giannis is going to be dunking on the
sixers tonight he actually has a funny
gift of somebody ducking on a little kid
shout out to you uh thomas444 you walk
away with a hoodie here we go i want to
give away this jersey aaron i want to
give away this jersey
and i'm gonna give it away to made you
luca made you luca says winners only
please and i told them the type winners
only please and they will be walking
away with jersey so shout out to you
made to luca
aaron
i've been saying it since day one i've
been saying it since day one steph curry
is a lock for mvp
last night he showed us why let's take a
look
30 at the top with the step back it is
unbelievable yes look at that give me
that easy give me that 30 he also has
the floater game aaron do
he also has the floater game step back
to the side
he does it all money cash money here
goes the floater aaron it might be one
of the best in the nba
not only was he scoring aaron but he had
10 assists watch this one
two that's actually his brother-in-law
damien lee uh i've been sanders since
day one steph is amazing he should have
won mvp last year but uh things happened
but this year steph he's he's going off
he put up a 50-point game against the
hawks last night taking the warriors to
nine and one and moving into the
favorite position for mvp i need you
guys to get in the comments and tell me
who do you think is a lot to win mvp
we're looking at the odds right here
steph started at eight plus 800 and he
is now down to plus 250 aaron
now that steph has limited value do you
see any other contenders here
well first off guys greg is not lying he
has been saying steph curry for mvp as
we can see this line has moved down to
plus 250 like he said steph had his 10th
50-point game of his career which is
absolutely insane just the third
warriors player in franchise history to
do so with 50 points 10 assists but in
terms of this line yes it has come down
and it will probably continue to come
down if the warriors play the way they
are 9-1 and steph curry keeps putting up
these points like crazy but i will say
that we've seen a lot of movement in
this market we are only ten games in for
the warriors so throughout the next
couple of weeks things will shift for
example luka doncic he moved back from
being the preseason favorite you still
have kd up there giannis up there uh
joel embiid moves back slightly
considering that he does have coveted
he's going to be out for 10 days that
was something i said preseason to make
sure you are aware of the health and
availability of some of these players
but again we cannot predict covid so
that's something to definitely take in
consideration when looking at these
long-shot mvp candidates definitely
something to take into consideration
despite despite steph
and a 9-1 record the warriors are still
aaron not favorites to win it all let's
take a look at the odds is 8 plus 850
good value for golden state here
i think it is but i also think that this
line can yo-yo a lot just as everything
else kind of
has below let's say brooklyn the lakers
and milwaukee those three pretty much
remained consistent as you said golden
state moving up a lot of people really
like golden state they like them
preseason and now steph is giving them
even more reasons why we cannot count
them out but again in a market like this
i would still go with the long shot i
for example like miami 12 to 1 just
because better value of course and plus
850 but again like the mvp you are gonna
have to factor in the health and
availability of some of these players we
still have a little bit of drama going
on in brooklyn we have drama still going
on in philadelphia so as the season
progresses hopefully some of those
things will shake out but there is still
good value on golden state plus 850 of
course but i do think the line will
yo-yo around
take it now
i'm telling you guys take the warriors
now i was probably telling you guys last
week and the week before that take the
warrior's future now but if i was
wanting to go with a long shot erin if i
wanted to go to long shot can we pull
this graphic back up can we pull the
graph back up because i want you guys to
look towards the bottom and you guys see
the phoenix suns
sitting at plus 1600 they were just in
the finals last year
so i mean if if i'm sprinkling money on
a long shot give me the phoenix suns i'm
in the handy dandy ipad right now
looking for locks looking for takes i
got a carl cadet says nick's to win it
all and that's a lock word to smith so
shout out to you uh carl you are walking
away with the hoodie i'm back into the
comments um
i got money muncher he's talking about
joel and beating your sixers he says
joel and b is going to lead his team not
only to the best record in the
conference but also to a ship mvp mvp
aaron
i would hope so
move it
extra work because ben simmons isn't on
the floor
but
fingers crossed hey and one more nicole
marquez says aaron and greg don't sleep
on kd without kyrie he's bawling and the
nets are starting to find their groove
with durant leading the way kd for mvp
aaron what's your take on kd for mvp
i do like him i mean as he mentioned i
mean kyrie is out so he does have to
pick up a lot of that slack and he's not
able to sit you know back to backs as
often as he did last season because they
had three huge players on the floor at
all times but
i i mean it i
rather take him to an mvp than take the
nets to win it all personally yes yes
yes yes kd is an assassin kd is the grim
reaper kd is the best player in
basketball but i don't know if he's
going to win mvp me personally but aaron
guess what it is tnt
tuesday fanduel is boosting the three by
two and not one but both games on tnt
the question is will there be two
three-pointers in the first three
minutes of
tonight's game today we asked you on
twitter which three by two will cash
will it be the bucks taking on the 76ers
or the trailblazers taking on the
clippers and aaron here are the results
wow stay close
yes it is pretty close but are you
surprised that portland and the clippers
are beating your sixers in milwaukee
i am not because i'm riding with trail
blazers clippers i mean dame got his
touch back last game against the lakers
with six three pointers made and then
for the clippers you have paul george
reggie jackson luke kenner at all
averaging three made three pointers per
game so i can't go with the struggling
bucks team against a philadelphia team
that is without their key players due to
koba 19 so for that reason i know it's
minus 125 it's not minus 110 which is
just slight value change basically there
so i would still rock with this team in
the later game for the three by two cash
aaron is rocking with the west coast for
the three by two let me hop into the
comments let me hop into the comments
erin and it appears they are rocking
with you i got ryan ray saying blazers
click not too surprising blazers clips
made you luca made you luca is in the
comments aaron sends blazers clips uh
i got the gyro man says yes both teams
are going are great at shooting i think
he's talking about your take the
portland uh clippers take uh shout out
to everybody that i just mentioned shout
out to everybody i just mentioned you
guys are all walking away with the
hoodie and it is apparent here it is a
very apparent we are all riding as a
family
the clippers
taking on the trail blazers we're riding
with the west coast tonight the west
coast slated games uh so yeah we need
vibes we need sunsets actually you guys
put sunsets in the comments go to the go
to the emojis and put a sunset to send
us vibes for this three by two we asked
you in the app aaron we asked them in
the app how many points will giannis
score tonight against your 76ers what i
need everybody to do is get in the
comments and tell me how many points
giannis is scoring and at the end of the
game will dm one person who gets closest
and hook you up with a jersey aaron
giannis is sitting at 28.5 points
what do you think
so i'm going to go over in this game now
giannis is averaging 27 points a season
25 on the road but the bucks have been
in a slump with two tough back-to-back
losses first against the knicks and then
on the then against the wizards um on
sunday so i think giannis is definitely
going to have a chip on his shoulder
coming into this game especially against
the depleted 76ers so i'm gonna go with
the over in this one aaron is rocking
with the over i like that pick i do
think giannis is coming in with the chip
on his shoulder with something to prove
in philadelphia tonight against a sixers
team that's a little beat up aaron they
are a little beat up so giannis is going
to come up there with his
his his his his arms flexing
and probably flex on the sixers tonight
but i'm in the comments i am in the
comments i got uh
i i i got i got jt for mvp shouting out
uh jt for mvp zero he's shouting out the
sunsets vibes i asked for sunsets i
asked for
vibes for three by two so shout out to
jt mvp zero you are walking away with
the hoodie uh i have will huntington
will huntington also going with the over
he says giannis will score 31 points and
he's betting that quoted he said that
he's betting that shout out to you will
huntington aaron i got one more eddie on
the go eddie on the go says giannis is
scoring 37 tonight
giannis is scoring 37 tonight remember
please remember after the game we're
gonna hit you guys up
the person that is the closest the
person who is the closest we're gonna
hook you guys up with the jersey after
the game
aaron
let's talk some major markets money line
against the spreads and point totals for
tonight's game let's take a look at the
odds aaron what are you seeing here and
what do you like
so i'm going to go with the west coast
game we're going with the portland
trailblazers on the money line that has
moved down just slightly now portland is
owen 4
on the road that is their record they
have not won a game on the road so far
this season i don't see them losing all
five games on the road they're coming
off consecutive wins and if we take a
look back these two teams have played
each other the trailblazers were crushed
by 30 at los angeles on october 25th
four days later they got revenge and
were able to win so we do have a sample
size on this this will be the third
meeting and i'm banking on the portland
trailblazers to get the win so i took
them on the money line
aaron is is went with the trail blazers
on the money line they haven't won a
game
on the road this year but the vibes i'm
feeling the vibes aaron i am feeling
those vibes i want you guys to look at
that point total over there for the
trail blazers clippers it's sitting at
221
the trailblazers have went under in four
straight games and four straight games i
think that changes tonight i think that
this one's gonna go over uh let me hop
into the comments let me hop into the
comments
i got
afraid afraid 42 says bucks
spread clippers money line two locks for
us shout out to you afraid 42 you are
walking away with a hoodie i'm back into
the comments aaron i'm back into the
comments and i got seth not steph seth
not steph hot take i'm liking the sixers
odds even without embiid wow oh
loving this love waiting on tobias
as well just keep that in mind guys well
i mean
they're they're they're throwing takes
all in the comments uh
k-pots says the over is easy money
everybody that i mentioned everybody
that i mentioned you guys are walking
away with the hoodie aaron we talked
major markets now let's talk player
props one of our favorites we're going
to play a little gamer we're going to
play a little game called lock or not
i'm going to put up a prop and you guys
at home
get in the comments and tell me if it's
a lock or not
are you guys ready erin are you ready
i'm ready let's do it this will be a fun
game all right let's do it let's do it
with the first one the first one
we got seth curry not steph curry seth
curry
over two and a half three points made
sitting at -13 is this a lock or is it
not aaron what do you think
it's a lock i mean look he's not steph
curry but seth curry as we know can go
off and considering all the players that
are
basically not playing obviously for the
philadelphia 76ers student coven we need
someone to go off and for that reason i
like seth to go over first three
pointers made i think in one game he had
seven made three pointers which was
absolutely incredible six in the first
quarter something crazy like that
towards the beginning of the season so
we have seen this from him and we can
count and depend on him so for that
reason i am going to say it's a lock
love your point there love your point we
know the sixers have some injuries so
steph curry is gonna have to step up he
is gonna have to show up and he has in
clutch moments for the sixers team this
year so i think
he is going to go over the two and a
half three points made but aaron let me
hop into the comments let me hop into
the comments because i'm seeing
they think steph has been on fire i see
steph has been on fire shout out to you
afraid 42 uh i see wills back in the
comment over i'm a bucks fan but we can
see the bucks fans are keeping it real
in the comments uh here we go i got
i got jade wade 13 says yes they need
someone to cook seth is that guy shout
out to everybody i mentioned we uh you
all are walking away with hoodie uh it
appears they like steph curry to go over
let's go to the next one aaron drew
holiday over
26 and a half points rebounds and
assists do you like this is this a lock
or not
this is not a lock so he's averaging 13
points four boards three assists and
four games played this season so i am
not banking on this by any re by any
means i mean it seems pretty high
already at 26 and a half and maybe
they're taking into account that the
sixers again depleted as we keep beating
this dead horse with that but i don't
really like this towards the over
yeah i mean i'll have to agree with you
there is a lot of options and it's juice
minus 122 on the note4 re
there's a lot of options on this bucks
team and um
we've been talking about giannis and i
think the ball is going to be in his
hands quite often tonight and that's
going to limit points rebounds and
assists for jew holiday so i'm going to
rock with you aaron and i'm back into
the handy dandy to see
what the people are saying uh city
3184 says he is going to get his touches
in fact so he's fading what i just said
and said he's going to get in touch but
just because of that i mean just because
of the vibes just because of your take
you are walking away with the hoodie i
got one more in the air and i got one
more uh city 3184 is in the comments
below and it's it's love bro it is love
the sal vuk volcano the sal volcano says
uh he's gonna total 37 tonight 37 points
rebounds and assists therefore he's
fading our take again but it's love here
on
it's love here it's it's just love here
on the group chat it's love here and so
we're gonna give you guys hoodies uh
let's move on let's move on
we have paul george to be top scorer in
tonight's
portland versus the clippers game uh
aaron do you like that he's saying that
plus 100
are you rocking with paul george to be
the top scorer in that game dame is
playing aaron
damon is playing but i do think this is
a lock of plus money because paul george
leads the clippers with an average of 27
points per game but um just in general i
know we all have this thought in our
head that damien lillard has absolutely
been going off in previous seasons we
have made the case on the show i believe
even i did that he could be an mvp
candidate but cj mccollum's actually
leading the team for the trailblazers
with 22 points per game on the road and
at home meanwhile dame's only averaging
19 points per game and 18 on the road
while i do want the portland trail
blazers to win and i did say this
i think that there could be a case to be
made for paul george to go and be the
highest scorer in this game especially a
plus 100 i think it's better value
aaron aaron likes paul george to be the
high score in the game i i don't i don't
i i like her take on
uh portland winning the game and if
portland wins the game dame's gonna have
to go off so uh that would be my boat if
i had i mean if he was listed i'll be
riding dame but uh so i'm gonna take the
no here with paul george but i'm in the
comments it's not about what i think
right now it's about you guys it's
taking you guys getting some money i see
giannis time is in the comments says
it's a man's game tonight i'm not in pg
really not a lot tonight at least shout
out to you yannis time you are walking
away with a hoodie uh i got northeast la
said paul george can get competitive
with dave
it could be a competition uh shout out
to you northeast la uh
that that's it for the hoodies that's it
for the hoodies we love you guys take
you guys keep filling up those comments
keep filling up those comments we all
know you love the fanduel same game
parlay so br betting is now building our
own
and giving you guys the opportunity to
ride with us i'm about to give out
today's br betting's parlay but i need
you
to get in the comments and tell me what
do you think of the parlay
which legs or locks and which legs is
gonna bust the parlay this week we're
building a dame comeback parlay
are you ready aaron are you ready for
this dame parlay
yes let's do it all right here we go
let's get right into it let's get right
into it the first leg of the parlay
is i need dame to go get 25 points dame
score 25 tonight that's what we need
aaron do you like this take or do you
not
if he's going to go off in one
category i do think it will be points so
for that reason i do like that first leg
is good okay first leg is good we're
getting good vibes guys i need sunsets
need sunsets because we're gonna send
vibrations and we're gonna send
wavelengths and we're gonna send
positivity towards dame way in la
tonight because this this parlay is full
of dame let's move on to the next one
let's move on to the next one we got
dame four plus three points made aaron
send me your vibes are you feeling this
one is this a stretch
do you like it yes no stretch okay a
little bit of stretch bit of stretch but
last game he was able to do this against
the lakers when he got hot so i
understand it but the game before that
couldn't hit a three to save his life so
we're thinking we're gonna ride the wave
of he's you know getting back to the
normal day himself so we're remaining
positive about this comeback okay okay
it's a stretch but we're feeling good
we're feeling good he it's day it's damn
he can literally probably make four logo
three-pointers yeah you could probably
make four logo through boys so we're
we're okay let's move on to the next leg
the next slick we got dame dishing the
ball around we got him dishing the ball
around
eight plus assists aaron talk to me you
like this one or no
i like this one he's averaging nine
assists on the season so again another
leg i can get behind
aaron okay she sent this good vibe she
sent this good vibe for the third leg of
the parlay
last but not least and that's last but
not least here we go
dame go grab four rebounds aaron
do you think he can go grab four tonight
he's averaging four on the season so i
think he can this is really a part like
he really needs to go off tonight for
this to cash
yes yes yes dame i mean we're all in on
dame here uh we're gonna just call this
the dame game parlay instead of the same
game as the name game parlay let's pull
up the tickets so we can show you guys
let's pull up the ticket here we go
aaron if we was to put a hundred dollars
down
freaking 484 dollars back before i get
into the comments what are you grading
the br dain
game parlay
so this is a risky
parlay in the sense of you really are
counting on one player to go off and for
that reason that you are being so bold
or i should probably say the whole
company is being so bold on this one i
like it i'm going with an a minus on it
i think it's a good one it could
potentially cash especially if it goes
off i want dame to go up as i said i
took the portland trail blazer's money
line so i hope he does and then he hits
every category aaron i'm in the east
coast and uh i made an observation
they're a little aggressive on the east
coast but you you're from the east coast
but you're being very generous with the
a minus right there's so uh
i'm proof philly i'm aggressive
hey let it be known let it be no uh let
me get in the comments let me get in the
comments and see if they're great nor
are parlay as generous as you uh mgo
blue 16 gave us a c he gave us a cease a
see c's get degrees
uh c's definitely get the grease jason
hold one
jason jason wade 13 is giving us sunset
shout out to you jason for the good
vibes
terence demand says
this whole parlay depends on lillard and
i'm not liking the parlay against my
clippers not a lot today
b minus as a grade a guess what brother
terrence
b's also get degrees so i'll take that
we will take that here at br betting uh
that's it that's it for the comments
that's it for hoodies actually aaron
do you want to get in the comments and
give away a hoodie do you mind do you
want to
um let me pull it up on my handy okay
wow wow aaron is pulling it up while
aaron is pulling up quick
let me let me give one more let me get
out one more i got i got sandy goats in
that's a b minus gave us a b minus solid
b from north east l.a
shout out to you akiel 789 says very
bold parlay b-plus
love all the vibes love all the vibes
that is that is flowing all right here
we go
uh do we give one to jason wade 13. this
is a b plus very bold yeah
jason jason i don't know if i gave it i
don't know if i gave him one but jason
aaron chose you so if we gave you one
we'll send you two how about that we'll
send you to uh i can't keep up with so
many people that
that comment yeah the comments
the comments definitely definitely be
jumping uh in case you didn't see the
latest episode of best friends
on bleach report and br betting social
channels i went one-on-one versus
defensive player of the year
meta
world peace and uh i got some buckets
aaron i did get some buckets i'm gonna
show you the video but first i need you
guys to get in the comments and tell me
if you think you can get a bucket on ron
or tess let's take a look
you ready
oh that's one turnover
that was a fail
oh that's true
you gotta figure it out you gotta figure
it out
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
hey mikey didn't think i was gonna get a
bucket but i didn't get one bucket i got
two against him
aaron
what's your take that was so good oh
face see you're nice even though we
weren't able to get 10 on them i mean it
was it was good i liked that video too i
like that you're in uh warriors gear as
well very fitting i had to shut out the
words but i'll put my i'll put my
savings account that nobody in these
comments is going 10 for 10 against
metal world peace uh
but yeah i had to show up mikey and chad
ocho i had to let him know that uh you
know i've been doing this since 93 here
yeah 83 baby i'm a 96 baby oh
you're close you're both our years were
jordan rings yeah yeah jordan rings uh
aaron let me get into the comments let
me get into the comments
because i already know they might come
at me here we go greg the long lost
curry brother shout out to you maxwell
rexella uh
rich bartel says yes sir i can get
buckets shout out to you rich bartels we
might gotta set that up
sandy goats calls me trash uh sammy
goats we can set up a 1v1 me and you any
day brother i promise you that and uh we
can get buckets uh hey i got one more
emmy one more in me nicole
marquez i gave you a hoodie earlier
uh i saw you scoring twice on meta when
ocho only got one i can definitely get a
bucket on meta if you give me 10 tries
show me what you got nicole we might
have to set that up everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
hoodies aaron
i think it's time to get on the pot of
here i think it's time to get on up out
of here thanks for tapping in everybody
thanks for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel
remember what you learned today
the portland trailblazers versus the los
angeles clippers 3x2
is a lock giannis is going off steph is
a lock for mvp i've been saying that
since the beginning
and get on fanduel to tail the br
betting dane come back same par lay
we'll be right back here next week
giving out more hoodies giving out more
jerseys and most importantly more locks
if you want a hoodie today we will dm
you not me not aaron but br betting will
dm you and you know what
i just give out another hoodie aaron i
mean the people are here for hoodies so
might as well give them a hoodie uh here
we go
i got two that was waiting to the end
yeah the people at the end are the ones
that deserves it i got lillard time 100.
hoodie me before you leave i need the
tie-dye drip
guess what lillard time 100
you were walking away with some tie-dyed
trip you see it behind me there it is ah
get on fanduel and ride with us follow
us on social follow me follow aaron
follow be our betting follow fanduel
follow all of us on social alongside
aaron dolan i'm greg ivory we are
leaving the group chat
peace peace
[Music]
you